I'm ophthalmologist Ashley Brissette
let's answer some questions from Twitter
this is I support
[Music]
Stephen Murphy asks how does LASIK eye
surgery even work like what how does
that just let you see well I'll tell you
how it works I perform Lasik and I even
had Lasik done on myself what Lasik does
is it helps to remove microscopic layers
of tissue on the surface of the cornea
to better direct the light as it enters
the eye so that it's focused in your
retina the biggest risk is risk of
infection although it's quite rare less
than one in one thousand people would
ever develop an infection at jjd gmn
asks what do eyeballs feel like I mean
the closest thing I can think that it
feels like is a grape if you peel back a
layer here you can see how delicate this
tissue is so if you were going to
squeeze an eye it would kind of have the
same squishy consistency of a grape it's
filled with a jelly which is called the
vitreous and then the tissue layers of
the eye are really really thin almost
like this thin outer layer of the grape
when we're learning how to do surgery
sometimes we practice certain techniques
on things like grapes at Junior Barnaby
asks how to ophthalmologists know babies
need glasses one way we can tell that
babies need glasses is their eyes are
crossing turning in or turning out
another reason we can tell that babies
can't see or might need glasses is if
they're rubbing their eyes a lot
sometimes babies rub their eyes a tongue
because they're trying to stimulate
Vision another reason is if babies are
tilting their heads or if they're not
fixating on objects usually by about
three months babies should be able to
see a toy or an object and kind of
fixate on it and follow it if you move
it around at Mark's Fisher asks what is
the anatomical purpose of eyelashes
eyelashes actually exist to help trap
all the dust pollution bacteria
allergens that exist in the environment
so they don't hit the surface of the eye
it's actually proven that eyelashes
should be a specific length if your
eyelashes are too long it's trapping too
much of that in the environment and it
can sit there and cause irritation on
the eyes that's why it's so important to
be washing over your closed eyelids
every morning and evening to remove all
that's been trapped in the eyelids and
lashes at trans Regina L asks my right
eye twitches is this anxiety or
nervousness twitching is what's called
myokymia eyelid switch for a number of
reasons the most common is because of
lack of sleep to too much caffeine or
stress the muscles that are around the
eye are very delicate and very sensitive
to stressors at our dab Dao asks what
are the dangers of wearing contact
lenses while sleeping I always sleep
with contacts on I don't see any side
effects so far I have seen terrible
damage to vision from people that sleep
in their contact lenses our eyes get
their oxygen from the environment and
when you wear your contact lenses for
too long you deprive the eyes of oxygen
and that can leave you really prone to
developing an infection and you can
develop what's called a keratitis which
is an infection on the cornea which is
the surface layer of your eye can lead
to scarring and permanent damage to your
vision at Kevin Clark NWS why does
eyesight deteriorate with age eyesight
deteriorates with age mostly due to
cataract it happens to all of us as we
get older the Cataract is the clouding
of the lens which is on the inside of
the eye this gets more yellow big and
thick as we grow up and that changes the
prescription and also causes the vision
to be blurry cataract is actually the
world's leading cause of blindness but
it's reversible with the surgery it's
actually the most commonly performed
surgery around the world I go inside the
eye remove the cloudy Cataract and then
put a new lens implant in its place that
has your prescription in it it's an
artificial lens but it's really well
tolerated it's biocompatible and can
help to restore Vision add keelnut wants
to know what does 2020 vision mean 2020
Vision refers to how we measure your
vision on a vision chart so most vision
charts are set for 20 feet away if you
can see the 2020 line that means that at
20 feet away from the eye chart you can
read that line and we refer to that as
normal or perfect vision about 35
percent of the population can only see
that 2020 line without glasses or
contact lenses so say if you had 20 50
Vision which would be this line here
what that refers to is that what you
would be able to see at 20 feet being
this line here someone with perfect
vision would be able to see at 50 feet
away some people can even have better
than perfect vision so we would refer to
that as 2015 Vision if you were standing
at 20 feet from the eye chart the person
with normal vision would only be able to
see what you see if they stood closer at
15 feet to the eye chart no Amano
Thotties asks what does legally blind
even mean like can you be illegally
blind like can you get arrested for
being blind so legally blind refers to a
vision that is 2200 or Worse 2200 is
this Big E on the chart if you're
standing 20 feet away from the vision
chart this is the only letter that you
can read while somebody with perfect
vision would be able to stand 200 feet
away and also be able to read this e
this would be vision of 2200. at null
z27s do carrots actually improve your
eyesight or have my parents been lying
to me my whole life carrots actually
improve your eyesight they have
beta-carotene which is an important part
of the vitamin A pathway there's
actually big studies that we've done
that look at nutrients and how they
affect your vision the main nutrients
that are recommended are vitamin A
vitamin C vitamin E lutein and
zeaxanthine these vitamins that are
recommended are really important in the
metabolic pathway of the cells that are
in your retina which is that Vision
sensory organ of the inside of the eye
at access wants to know how do people
know they're colorblind you might know
it's not right because you'll start to
sense that there aren't as many
differences in colors most people who
are colorblind it's not that they can't
see color it's that colors are much more
muted we can actually test it though
these are what are called ishihara color
plates so if you're colorblind you might
not see this red number six in the sea
of green similar to this one you might
not be able to see the green s in the
sea of red the most rare form of color
blindness is blue color blindness so you
might not be able to see the ton here in
the sea of blue at Fair b14 wants to
know seriously though where do eye
floaters come from eye floaters are a
natural part of the eyes Anatomy your
eye is filled with a jelly it's called
the vitreous this jelly starts to
liquefy as we grow up when it liquefies
you get clumps of cells and collagen
which are in this jelly that Clump
together and then cast a shadow on the
retina so the floater that you're seeing
moving around is just kind of a clump of
cells in this now liquefied vitreous
jelly casting a shadow in the back of
your eye at Miss Claire 18 asks where do
these tears come from tear years come
from the lacrimal glands it's a gland
that is in the upper outer corner of
your eyelid the purpose of Tears is to
help keep your eyes lubricated our eyes
need to be lubricated for us to see
clearly through that's why people that
have dry eye feel like their vision is
blurry and their eyes feel really
uncomfortable at Meg stand asks I hate
having to get my pupils dilated at the
eye doctor what is the purpose of that
other than giving me a migraine the
reason we need to dilate your eyes is to
take a look inside the back of your eye
as you can tell the pupil it's really
hard to see through it if it's small so
by using the chemicals phenylephrine and
tropicamide they help to dilate that
Iris muscle so that I can actually see
into the back of your eye that's why
it's so uncomfortable when you leave the
office your pupils are really dilated so
much light is getting through the way
that I can see in the back of your eye
is by using a light on a microscope
device such as this which can then
magnify the view into the back of the
eye we can tell a lot about your total
body health so I can learn if you have
high blood pressure if you have diabetes
even Sometimes some autoimmune
conditions this is showing a normal eye
this is the retina which is like the
back wall paper lining layer of the eye
these are all the blood vessels which
look really normal and healthy here is
the nerve that's the cable that connects
the eye to the brain that sends the
visual signals to your brain in contrast
this is actually a photo of an eye with
diabetes there's some bleeding spots the
blood vessels look what we call tortuous
which means that they're a little bit
twisted and all of these yellow deposits
here are swelling or what we refer to as
exudates as you can imagine all of this
here can actually cause damage to the
vision at sea party 25 wants to know
what's the difference between an
ophthalmologist an optometrist and an
optician so an ophthalmologist goes to
medical school they perform any medical
procedures and they do surgery on eyes
as well such as Lasik cataract surgery
glaucoma surgery optometrists go to
Optometry schools so they do General Eye
Care glasses prescriptions and contact
lenses prescriptions and an optician is
someone who makes the glasses that
Serena males as our eyelash extension
safe so my answer is sometimes if you
have the Lash extensions on and they're
too long it's keeping too much of the
bacteria and dust and pollution that
gets trapped in them that just leads to
bacterial overgrowth and eventually
infections I also see a lot of damage
that people get from the chemicals that
are used in terms of gluing them onto
your natural lashes and sometimes I've
seen People's Natural lashes fall out
because of an issue with an allergy to
the glue the lashes can grow back so if
your eyelashes fall out it takes about
two months for them to come back if
you're really going to play around with
beauty trends only do it for a special
occasion and then give your eyes a break
at Liam Paws underscore FFXIV wants to
know what's the difference between near
and farsighted nearsighted is when you
can see up close but it's really
difficult to see far away that's
actually the most common prescription
error that most people have farsighted
is when you're able to see somewhat far
away but really difficult seeing up
close at a Lexus k97s question for
optometrists out there why do I see
shapes and colors when I rub my eyes
what actually is that the eyes filled
with a jelly and when you press on the
eye the jelly then presses on the retina
and it stimulates it similar to like if
light entered the eye to stimulate it
this is where those rods and cones those
photoreceptors are so it's why it's
important not to be rubbing your eyes
because you're kind of just squishing
your eyeball at dodgson is here as I've
never understood how marijuana can be an
effective treatment for glaucoma like
how is Extreme paranoia supposed to help
your eyes marijuana is not a recommended
treatment for glaucoma yes marijuana can
have a very small very temporary effect
of lowering your eye pressures we know
that high eye pressure is a risk factor
for glaucoma but marijuana only lowers
it for a really short period of time and
not enough that would actually be of any
benefit at Yash archive wants to know
how did the eye test work I mean they do
so many seemingly random things the
first thing that we test when you come
for an eye exam is the vision so they'll
flip back and forth between the
different prescriptions to see what
prescription do you actually need what
these lenses do is they help to focus
the light so that it lands right on the
back of the eye so that it brings
everything into Focus for you then we
test your eye pressure that's that puff
of air test that everybody hates having
done when the air puff test hits the
front of the eye it's actually measuring
how much it decompresses the front of
the eye and the rebound and that gives
us a general sense of the pressure on
the inside of the eye we know that high
pressure in the eye can lead to damage
in the nerve the nerve is the cable that
connects your eye to your brain and
that's what gets damaged in glaucoma the
last thing that we're going to do is
look at your eyes underneath a
microscope which is called a slit lamp
it's this big machine you're going to
put your chin on the chin rest so we can
actually look inside the back of your
eye if the nerve is getting bigger
that's a sign of glaucoma damage a
phenomenal underscore Nissa asks is the
blue light filter actually good for eyes
there is no evidence that using the blue
light blockers helped with eye strain
with computer use it was a great
marketing tool but a big research study
came out that showed no benefit for eye
strain using the blue light blockers
most of the eye strain occurs because of
glare so you can get an anti-glare cover
for your screen and that can help add D
Palmer 216 as what kind of drugs is
Zuckerberg on that his pupils are always
dilated I never noticed that and I don't
want to get on his bad side but there's
a few reasons why your pupils dilate one
is if you're in dim lighting and that's
to allow more light to enter the eye
another reason pupils can dilate is from
some medications or some drugs
stimulants such as cocaine MDMA
sometimes even some antidepressants it's
a side effect of the medications lastly
your pupils sometimes dilate if you're
in love or if you're aroused so if you
see somebody that you love the pupils
dilate and that's because you get a
release of dopamine and the dopamine
leads to the dilation at just simply
Sally asks what happens when you look
directly at the Sun so you can sunburn
your eyes UV damage can occur on the
eyeballs it can cause something called
photokeratitis which is a sun damage to
the surface of the eye but it can also
cause damage to the retina in the back
of the eye it damages those fine
photoreceptors which are used for
sensing Vision if you look at the Sun
for say longer than 90 seconds that can
cause this damage flavor of Gabby asks
did you know that we actually see things
upside down but the sensors that connect
our brain and our eyes flip the image
yes I did know that and not only does it
flip the image from up and down it also
flips it from left to right thinking of
the eye like a camera it actually
travels through the entirety of the eye
the first thing it hits is the cornea
which is the a clear cover layer of the
eye then it travels through the lens
which helps to direct the light rays
into the macula which is the back part
of your retina this nerve here is made
up of 1.3 million little axons which are
connections that allow the image to be
distributed through the brain all the
way into the back of your brain called
the occipital region so by having lots
of different input lots of different
connections from our visual world that
helps to provide depth of field depth of
focus and gives you really great clarity
for your vision next question is there a
thing where your eyes can change color
my eyes have never been this light
before your eye color is pretty set by
about one year of age your eyes can
appear to look different colors it
usually has to do with the amount of
lighting colors that you're wearing the
reason why people have different eye
colors is the amount of melanin or
pigment in their Iris which is the
colored part of the eye so people with
blue eyes have less melanin and people
with brown eyes have more melanin at
only one lvm asks how do people become
cross-eyed we call this strabismus
strabismus means a turning in or a
turning out of the eyes you have to be
able to see clearly for your brain to
use the two eyes together and if one of
the eyes isn't seeing very well then the
brain starts to ignore one of the eyes
ignores those muscles and the eye starts
to drift or turn so those are all the
questions for today those were some
really great questions my biggest pieces
of advice make sure you're washing over
your closed eyelids eating well and just
stay healthy thanks for watching I
support